[Music]
they sustained
the moment we've all been waiting for
Hootie PI hands-on versus none other DJ
I mean the t-virus that's what we're
here to eradicate the t-virus my name is
Jack PewDiePie and welcome in its time I
have fought in many battles many
challenges as you can tell by my fix
welcome for the last and this is where
it all comes down to you they says eight
look at this green screen impeccable
[Music]
okay alright y'all know why we're here
now let's just jump into it how are you
guys doing sorry I'm late I couldn't get
to I couldn't get them [ __ ] audio to
work and I still can't get it to work so
we're just gonna have to go with it it's
just one of those big hack to my
computer I know it nice camera quality
thank you
finally someone who knows what's up so
we are here we are here to play table G
mobile that's right they updated it with
a very nice survive till dawn rested an
evil cross over a very epic look at that
you can play as resident evil lady look
at me very sexy wow you look so sexy
but most importantly we're here to fight
the t-virus I didn't want to go so far
as call it a virus but that's what it
actually is
now if anyone in the comments knows how
I record audio at the same time the Bo
gotta let me know that would be great
thank you thank you very much if you
guys want to play with me
you can download it link is in the
description and we can eradicate the
t-virus together as a family as a as a
team a family of teams and love and
lovers maybe potentially lovers Jay mica
drongo let's go boys thank you very much
let's see how many comments about the
bridge we got in the chat
oh great nothing at all that's awesome
now apparently you have to be level 10
to it you have to be level 10 to play
this mode and I'm level 9 so we're gonna
have to play a little bit of classic old
pub G good ol classic mean pub G
everyone why is it doing
now I'm playing on the my epic honor
phone I need to wait please
damn it okay so I need to actually I
need to do one regular game and win it
survive till dawn and then we will
eradicate zombies I mean T virus the
green screen is perfect is that what you
guys said
thank you is it better now oh god I'm
turning into one of them damn this is
pretty cool can you guys hear the
gameplay at all I hope I don't get any
text messages when I play this
I chose whether to add the audio just so
I can hear it and play good or it's
shitty through my speakers and I chose
to chitti oh wait maybe I can connect
this or Bluetooth now I think about it I
don't think my computer has bluetooth
for the love of God I don't think this
map actually has any bad stuff in it so
fix the green oh okay sorry I thought
the green screen was good I may have
gotten the wrong idea
all right let's get that chicken dinner
yeah we're playing happy Willis that's
it leave it like bits okay I'm curious
should I check like it's like I can look
at my phone but I can also look at the
screen it's really weird I don't know
where like where to look okay
Paradise Resort now it's been a while
since I play I'm a low rusty all right
who jumps paradise resort anyway why is
the graphics better on the mobile
version honestly look at this then on my
computer
the audio is muted near the map that
makes sense
watch me get it chicken then or first
try boys easy this is going to be
legendary we're playing with cara cara
Vedran and joshi pub i realized they can
hear me but i can't hear them
there we go hey what's up team how's it
going bro are you all ready for this
cool well this should be very exciting
all right let's get this bread pull it
loops that's that's the first thing you
want to draw all right let's go all
right we're good hey Jesus Christ I did
that on purpose to draw them out I know
what I'm doing way I should look up here
it's a little weird but I see so much
bigger as well look at that it's like -
half a second delay it's pretty good you
know if I didn't say it I wouldn't know
it I'm playing on mobile one do you
pretty epic so I think I actually have
to win to rank up so lot of pressure the
pressure is definitely on on me guys AKA
is the best gun really I'd run past it
though all right let's get it I like the
SMGs cuz I can't aim in this game so
I'll just go for that for now alright
thank you so much for the tips guys
really appreciate it if you have any
more tips just let me know it could be
whatever just make sure that no not
everyone in the goddamn chat has already
said it that's all I ask
okay you ain't slick is what I'm saying
I don't play on an iPhone what do you
think I'm some scrub Android okay that's
why the graphics are good all right
literally someone could be next to me
and I wouldn't be able to hear it why am
I wearing these don't even need them
there we go there we go why is no one
else dropping here where's my teammates
they mark this area oh they all drop
there what a bunch of scrubs oh god they
can hear me sorry guys I didn't mean
that but you're bad okay
sorry but someone has to say it t-series
is the best Wow band that guy how dare
you I cannot believe it
no they are the best ah Jesus my
character disagrees no wait
when did I pick this up what happened to
me okay
what the hell where do you go not good
this is Oh
someone's nearby okay okay I got this I
got this I got this
watch this watch this
oh there's a king whatever I need to
kill look at this look at this Pro I'm
ready to go pro right here's someone
else they'll never know [ __ ] now they
don't know
where's his teammate
come on substitute a pion wind that's
right for every subscriber I get during
this live stream I will get another
subscriber and that would be really cool
okay my backpack is full what do we got
I got a 4x on my um that's really good
drop drop it quit
pretty damn intuitive alright so well if
you guys want to play with me and you
don't have the game make sure you play
now and level up because you need to be
level 10 and hopefully I'll I'll get a
little time I think I'll get level 10
do you hear anyone that reads it just me
keep trying to pull up the volume
alright let's let this scrub Wow bad
just bad oh you hear that
that's gunshots I don't know if you guys
knew that Oh get ass eaten that's right
that's what I'm talking about Pro I got
to hear people G says where they go oh
now that's pro play that's pro play
right there
I'm playing against bots again aren't I
no I'm Pro okay did you see that spin
around not anyone can do that only real
pros I don't know what else I need
really rapidity pretty loaded don't
forget to reload your extended mags what
do you think I'm some scrub let's get
this guy who's shooting doko desu ka'
come on come at me where do they go
where are you I will just this is not
camping this is finding searching am I
using emulators no I'm playing on the
phone okay I have such a great phone
that I can have amazing graphics
that's why make sure you're in the zone
I am get the scope dude I have a scope
you scrub stop leaving [ __ ] tips all
right we're good in the map
I'm trying to understand what the hell
you guys are saying open your backpack I
don't need to okay maybe I did maybe I
need to sort out a couple things there
you go you happy
I hear him right am I crazy
it's hard to hear because my sis is
vacuuming my mic is on well it's on T oh
[ __ ] it's in all so everyone is hearing
me
[Laughter]
I hope they heard me I guess the speaker
should be on all then oh god stop why do
you do that I keep hitting on the left
sign wishes better fortnight or pub G
pop G mobile baby it's the only game
you'll ever need in your life after
maybe maybe now you know what it's
number one god damn it alright I'm gonna
move cuz this is boring don't know where
to go though
in the UK you don't vacuum you Hoover
well that's because you're a bunch of
dumb balls okay and you don't know what
vacuuming is is that a silencer what is
that
no it is ah Jesus I already have a
silencer this game is still relevant you
got that right god damn it
is there anyone else like I keep hearing
stuff but it's like my own footstep all
right 35 alive come on let's see some
pro level gameplay why do they mark out
there it's so annoying
alright well my teammates are getting
known what's the sub cap what's the sub
cap I forgot I forgot to pull it on the
screen
no I haven't been goddammit this is not
zombie mode yeah I need to level up Jill
we'll do it after this one okay just
relax I'm full of [ __ ] honestly I think
I have everything I need you need to
come to Russia feel extreme with the red
from the Red Square to defeat history me
Mars actually wanted to go to Russia but
then we understood it's really you have
to like apply for a visa and it's kind
of a process and we just couldn't be
bothered
sorry Russia my phone seems like an iPad
does this look like an iPad to you you
dumb ball it's almost I was 30 K that's
pretty good this some guys a 30 King
good job guys you keep holding in turn I
keep subscribing I'm sure I'm sure like
I'm sure YouTube is just gonna nuke it
out of nowhere they're just gonna remove
like a hundred K and be like ah [ __ ] it
that would be the worst like if teaser
is gonna win at least win with like a
countdown not just YouTube being like a
[ __ ] you that's all I ask
oh I see a guy let's go stealth from
this [ __ ] damn damn I'm good did you
guys see that did you guys see that
epic shocked kill very nice headshot
right in the head I aim for the head
always aim for the head
double damage everyone knows this all
right well he had nothing compensator
but I have silencer
turn on peak and fire what is that is
that in the settings aim-assist oh wow
that was on that's supposed to be off I
gotta hear someone who's here ah either
everywhere but it's happening that
wasn't him right
snake mode snake mode now back to
settings peak and fire unable what does
that mean
what does speak and fire do okay maybe
it helps I don't know peek and open
scope what does that means peek you know
when scope very confusion that my
teammate hey what's up man do something
good
all right cool he's Pro you can tell
yeah it is amazing graphic I know what
are you doing whoa okay this is peak how
do I get that oh sorry sorry sorry sorry
oh okay so I can hit those okay that's
kind of cool how do I get out of it
there we go is that what you guys
talking about
take the painkiller well well well well
we have a bunch of backseat drivers in
here ah get some way I got I got this I
think I got him I think I got him you're
welcome my teammates that got him no no
that was me that was all me baby which
is why I take the loot because I did all
the work
shoot with left fun yeah I need to start
doing that all right I have a bike now
so that's that thing is this kind of
hard because I'm looking at a bigger
screen
I don't really know where my fingers are
going
okay almost time time tv2 very well I'm
feeling I'm trying very hard to save you
please watch my effort I need more
support from bro army okay I'll check it
out right now I'm a snake that's right
it's snake time baby
this is Swedish military strategic at
hand this is how we won the ancient Wars
this is how we got Danmark
this is how we got Norway you fight
snakes with snakes that's right damn my
teammate is killing it all right let's
just [ __ ] this honestly I need to do
this get some bread let's get those
kills I need to rank up over here it
again
where are they come out oh he went down
what a noob what a loser oh dude he's
getting [ __ ] crawl oh wow well well
well looks like it's up to pudy pie the
number one snake what can I not see them
are they behind me I'm really I'm in the
middle aren't I
all right let's keep sneaking
boost up fine
gosh all right we got gamers over here
but we also have bushes over here Oh
someone died over there let's go to this
tree no one ever suspects a tree change
your scopes no you guys are crazy
I can barely use the red dot I'm gonna
change now I mean look at the map where
the shots are coming yeah I've been
doing that that's helpful
anyone gonna come from here come become
like I'm like imma come with me oh Jesus
bombs over Ghana change the scope change
the scope they said that's what idiots
do
oh they got smokes and [ __ ] over there
alright push time should I use my
headphones but then you guys can't hear
anything I see him okay
why had I lost vision yeah I think
someone else killed him
is he in there I can't see yeah he is
nope nope fine
I mean the map
hey where did that ah oof big oops why
would you do that
how could he have possibly known that I
suspect hacks and cheats I see him in
the house by the way all right banished
time all right hey I have adrenaline oh
[ __ ] he's running out yes stay right
there oh god it's so fine
hey don't shoot a switch man don't shoot
a Swedish main you didn't do nothing
where'd he go oh yeah oh God
good shooting oh [ __ ] it's me and had my
god
[Music]
he doesn't know about the snake he
doesn't know the power so he's over here
right I'm not in the circle I just
realized where's the circle down there
well he's got to move first we'll wait
for him
I see no Rosie
okay I'm confused are shades Bamie [ __ ]
what oh [ __ ] you you know I don't even
care that I seriously get cut in the end
goddammit t-series win nope no why did I
get up because I had to move okay
stop asking stupid questions look at
this [ __ ] team did nothing
you did nothing hide I'm okay you killed
four people whatever you did not think
oh nine well whatever they did something
doesn't matter it doesn't matter who
kills why t-series got up damn identical
yes we're level ten thank God all right
so now we can do what we sought out to
do and Edgar have joined the party
what's up Edgar invited me to a team
charity that was exciting that's a good
game what's up Christian
I bring us can you hear me man
he just started I didn't even click okay
okay here we go
defeat zombies in two nights survive
till dawn
hey Christian what's up man you found me
are you doing my client I have a client
oh [ __ ] okay well I want to make my own
claim okay I will make my own client or
should I call it no no no no no no [ __ ]
t-virus that's it that was perfect nice
okay I never played this mode before is
it good okay cool wait is this is not
zombie mode is it okay it is okay great
so you're you're Christian right
okay I'll jump with you vaccinator okay
run run me through what you do here
besides killing zombies okay
okay that's cool so I'm basically moving
exactly as you're moving now is that how
it works okay all right I'll check it
out
so it's basically the same thing but
there's zombies as well did I get that
right yeah okay cool okay
way I want to say it all right it's fine
fine whatever I don't care
hell yeah dude what are you doing
Dylan stop Dylan Dylan not cool billing
[ __ ] Dylan why I need to live it a
bit ain't got an armor yet
Oh found the common bond knife okay got
it easy oh Jesus Christ
okay let me know if you find my best or
some [ __ ]
or maybe it's not that neat it I don't
know okay should we just get going then
talk so what was the client I joined you
know let's go okay okay
very nice okay we'll find a car then I
haven't seen any zombies yet okay dude
you don't even have a weapon yet oh you
have one okay never mind
oh I see guys look
oh it's Dom be okay let me use the knife
thing
dude that's a fat one can i knifing oh
hell yeah oh yeah oh whoa oh [ __ ] they
got Luden's flamethrower mind my my my
my my my hell yeah oh yeah
jeez say what the [ __ ] is that liquor
cheese said oh he's got a car 98 got
damn oh I see it that's it
it's pretty dope damn they changed him
stuff oh yeah that's what I wanted to do
you might have heard something what does
that mean what are you guys doing oh I
say okay damn look at this gradient so
ecstatic oh look at that
oh god they don't even care about me
there you go hmm three kills how many
you got oh yeah oh really
[ __ ] [ __ ] where's the one getting the
big one
hey big one hey big one hey oh Jesus oh
he's dancing I like that
oh yeah okay nice
hey hey [ __ ] damn sixgills more oh I say
okay let's do that then oh nice nice
good job
[ __ ] it's too dark now I can't see any
I'm on the roof
oh god oh god [ __ ] up
yeah yeah look at that
oh yeah can they open doors okay I'm
just gonna I'm gonna do one of these
there you go
[ __ ]
nice oh it's that [ __ ] sound yeah I
don't know sounds uh nasty
never again whoa she says oh hell yeah
thanks appreciate it buddy
I need to hear that Oh
oh yeah it's barbecue time
oh ho [ __ ] they don't drop anything good
okay
hello [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] my tree look at nice okay well I'm
almost full anyway [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
my areal oh now Dan the flamethrower is
awesome hey we made it we made it
through the night how many nights are
there in each game okay where seems
aaahm be should we just stay here okay
stop camping I don't think so Oh
okay oh wait I don't have a vest [ __ ]
I'll go find one cool this is all Luton
wait you got you got knocked I thought
you were good wait I do have a vest
where do I why can I not pick it that
wanna talk yeah what happened well
goddamn guess it's up to me
No there we go okay it's fine okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what a coward
would do okay exactly and I've killed
0la Queen there you go
I know what I'm doing revive your
teammate Oh where's e it's too far back
guys
you heard it here first a my fault
[ __ ] ah Sh oh that's a big one she says
cranes is better have a lot of stuff in
it how do I pick up the ammo oh there we
go
Thanks
nope come on there you go yes this is it
oh jeez that [ __ ] scare me all right
I'm gonna keep moving
oh there's bosses dude I want to check
that I know what I'm doing okay oh [ __ ]
are they on the roof they're on the roof
Monday I would never do it such a thing
that would be highly yeah
should I just drive through the night
[ __ ] where's again why am i blind
okay I see I see oh [ __ ] I'm all out of
gas oh [ __ ] where do I go okay we'll go
there these [ __ ] left me a car with
no gas to die I can't believe it oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] go in ah okay okay good
it begins it begins here we go
why won't you [ __ ] buy she said
what's hitting me oh it's a liquor yeah
god [ __ ] damn it
oh my god ah God never
don't loot he'll bark real oh I'm so
[ __ ] stressed out get out never is he
stuck or something
Oh God
don't think so zombie don't think so
okay Oh God
[ __ ] Oh God oh [ __ ] me what is that I'm
done I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm done
get out I'm dying ah how long is this
night going it's fine
zombies are slow right
I'm stressed out I mean it I mean I mean
boy look at that pro gameplay happening
right here okay I don't think I need
anymore
okay so oh I'm in the zone
well metaphysically I'm in the zone okay
how do you know that my chat on the
street
okay thanks stream what else have they
say th all right well I mean I've been
useful
looks like it's just me here yeah all
right I heard silent shot wait so I
gotta check this From Russia With Love
is let down your gameshow thank you very
much
hot Jukes in your Oh God
I think that's Amazon that's my Amazon
delivery send your pie actual Pub GM Pro
streamer oh that's awesome hot chicks
happy to show you the way on OBS in a
game already got my sub - PewDiePie
shirt on that's cool thanks man hit me
up in the game if you want to play I'll
play with more people next time okay
hopefully that didn't show my [ __ ]
number Jesus Christ it's gonna be the
stream where I'd doc Doc's myself I'm
sure of it
well what's the number on the street
don't call the number
it's my Amazon delivery no wait what
what are you coming from that side now
say that again
you still there man I can't hear
anything
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I got effed hard
what is happening why is it coming from
here thanks bro alright well I
appreciate the help thank you for
walking me through it I'm gonna play
with more and just random people if
that's alright
so we'll say our ideas it was great
we'll never forget it Dylan honestly I
need to fix out I don't know I don't
know what happened with my phone
okay just give me one second
brooch and let's do another game third
we got second and third but we need that
dinner use my headphones maybe I should
just do that where are they
it's weird I don't know what happened
with the audio but then you guys can't
hear them and then I just sound insane
when I talk to random people I don't
know why like I'm using how I always
record but some reason audio doesn't
want to show up in my computer oh look I
hear myself does anyone know how to fix
a very stressing - what did I just get
booted out no not my account not my
precious account I just got to level 10
okay I still have my account
it's kinda laggy I think something
happened to my phone number restart the
game and my phone what in the world is
happening
okay I'm restarting you can play with an
emulator wouldn't I be cheating I didn't
think of it that's awesome it's actually
a great idea just link the game with
your social media I should probably do
that
okay restarting show the gap yeah let's
do that actually some curious what are
where are we at right now
PewDiePie versus t-series
sorry once again
almost sure my email that's always great
design I show up at you know what
[ __ ] I can't be mother alright let's
jump into another game
that was fun though I enjoy playing
though very hectic very disappointing
finishing okay so let's see how this
works
can you guys see this
there we go is it up
[Music]
now the livestream of this care
okay just send me an in mind let's
freakin get the bread the shame you guys
can't hear the game audio I'm sorry
audio is bad audio is amazing what
happened how does it sound for you guys
how does it sound for you guys how does
it sound for you guys hello testing
hello testing sounds amazing don't you
guys are talking it's repeating its
echoing really it's echoing
yes echoing because I was listening to
myself you dumb balls inviting you to a
team all right who invited me what's up
boys
can you hear me
fucking-a not here about audience no no
no cancel hello what's up xyx hi Marge
can you hear me hey
hey one second moist trying to figure
this out I'm restarting the game again I
think it's because I pulled in and out
of my headphones I won't keep saying put
in your headphones but Oh turn on the
mic yeah sure sure
good tip pro tip for overflow what does
that mean
okay let me restart again or just see
it's already working at all I'm just
gonna play fine no audio you got
completely cut okay now it works now it
works okay one second and we should be
good to go I know why I listen to you
guys it's working yes there we go now I
know even if my mic was off it didn't
matter because they had no audio on my
phone at all okay you guys think you're
slick you ain't slick
[Music]
come on
load up its load up uh-huh
load up you know I'm new to start around
again to see if the auto works
did you guys hear the audio
the audio echoed how how is that even
happening wait so you guys hear the
audio but I don't wait so you guys hear
the audio but wait so you guys hear the
audio my god
oh my god what is happening what is
happening oh my god
but now the order in the game works what
the [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah
you know
yo is it echoing now
is it echoing now let me know if your
insect going because I can't tell boot
camp it is no more heavy doesn't know
you know yeah deep
so audio is going
they step in
it's not don't tell you haven't done it
somebody moving anywhere but how am I
supposed to hear Chablis
how I said it can you guys hear the game
well what the [ __ ] happened now hello
now it's coming through my hello
I like our enemies would for some reason
if I turn on the [ __ ]
maybe Yuri if we do push-to-talk right
maybe then it will work no it doesn't
all right we're gonna have to do it like
this get [ __ ] boy where are you going
I don't I know audio in game is a bit
[ __ ] but that's that's the best I can do
okay and then we're gonna leave this cuz
yeah I know I know I know don't be sad
how do I leave this game yeah I know
yeah okay now we play where we came that
new survived
resident evil cross over plain thing
I have 50 friends
I'll join a team there we go
what's up supercharged how's it going
bro no I don't I live here you do your
thing there we go this is what I'm
talking about
very epic
I like this okay are you guys any good
at this you have two wins damn
cool it's really good to hear audio I
muted him sorry
sod stark clogged headphones to computer
and said Oh BA daba Damona game captures
on what yeah but the game is capturing
through my mic I don't know how the [ __ ]
that has got happening super weird yes
okay where are we jumping good ol prison
I should have just downloaded on PC yeah
I [ __ ] up here I watched thinking I
can stream from a phone no problem I was
wrong
it's fine this works fine kind of I
don't think we're gonna make it a prison
just just just a thought oh yeah perfect
this is where I wanted to go
very epic look at that yeah I got
nothing
we're screwed it's GG over before it
began well I think we knew that well G
says I thought it was someone else okay
no that's just discriminatory okay we're
not doing that
hey you got someone you got his nice
nice good job my in-game name is
PewDiePie forever number one it says
right there guys
honestly VR No number one of course why
would I think you have the t-virus what
okay
I'm going to school cuz I don't know
what else to do [ __ ] someone's been out
already here now you're high
good job
prior to you
nice job team I don't even remember
where that's from oh [ __ ] it is yeah
[Music]
poor Zach [ __ ] I want more Zach he just
disappeared after that someone from PR
probably went hey you can't speak
publicly anymore just a [ __ ]
cool I'm dead please help me I'm in the
bed I'll wait for you now I got it
[Music]
thanks
cold sure appreciate it
I'm alive
oh [ __ ] oh my god did you get him nice
oh yeah wait you died what are you new I
[Music]
win don't worry I got zero deaths you're
right about that I know what I'm doing
again don't even worry I don't know if
you know this but I'm kind of a big deal
kind of a pro-gamer kind of a prevalent
voice in the eSport community oh [ __ ]
that's fine hey what the [ __ ]
what are you come from Oz Chinese
Chinese that's not okay I'm sorry I let
you down man
your first bail I've never been this
disappointed
wait it is oh nice
okay let's do another one that was
pathetic that does not count oh I got a
message from my clan that's great we
hear you
yay was that what oh okay yeah I'm
having similar issues damn dude that's
higher than I am I'm ready you said you
never lost is that good you never play
okay I would say I started usually
releasing Lisa let's register each
other's channels sub4sub William Walker
thank you very much damn Alfie sorry I
didn't realize you guys heard me either
vaccinator nice this children won't die
[Music]
get their knees okay hello e God that's
life okay let's go for the win I need a
win please
are you stream sniping me dude what the
hell yeah yeah yeah you can't stream
tonight I'm gonna ban you now I'm sorry
it'll be an honor to be banned by you
see this is the right attitude that's
what I like to hear you subscribing
through yeah cams only only three
accounts dude I thought you were legit
then that's right then that's more like
you were trying to outplay
CaptainSparklez no one can do that
everyone knows that oh [ __ ] what is that
zombie
[ __ ] I'm dead I'm dead go go go I'm good
I'm good
easy no no I'm fine
I know exactly what I'm doing no no no
don't worry you know how many accounts
I'm so jeez it oh yeah
shoot him shoot him shoot him Chim Chim
Chim Chim Chim Chim Chim shut up shut up
shut up you're too [ __ ] thank you
it's cool I can hear myself like five
seconds after it's really cool you died
dude I thought you said you never fail
okay okay it's this dream sniper it is
isn't it
all right dude drop me some help hey hey
what are you doing here what's a friend
alright does he have a help no he didn't
[ __ ] useless Hey look I can get off
first I have my one-stop sales that's
pretty cool no well that's fine you can
do that that's alright
so long as you unsub the t series you
can sub to wherever you want
never what if what if oh god I'm dead
I'm dead
[ __ ] oh they were on the roof I come
away with a shotgun
thanks kills drawer you gay someone
refugee dude dude banned that person how
could you say that
I'm not gay how dare you not that it is
anything wrong with it
yeah do it thank you thank you very much
thanks for the right white okay good hey
that's right this guy knows what's up
I have a comment now there's a guy in
the building I'll do it anything okay
what do you see uh-huh okay good
someone shooting it okay yeah I see it
I just need a hill out what did you say
[ __ ] what happened who's shooting
[ __ ] me apparently sorry oh they are
yeah look at look at that little [ __ ]
nice good job sorry
[Laughter]
well at least they apologized yeah
exactly
thank you you have been no they have
been redeemed it's okay oh wait that's a
zombie and got time wait what what okay
okay I'm here look at this look at that
so good
Hey look they drop that I don't think
zombies have balls or do they that's
true some deep thinking going on here
asking the real question okay now is
just getting weird I don't know what to
tell you man
there's someone here it's alright
science gear where are you [ __ ] why do I
keep doing that
whoa okay wait what oh hell yeah
oh okay but stream snipers can get us
this is how the game is meant to be
behave this is not bad this is tactics
it sounds like you hacked the game they
put it in here so probe pro players
could use it it's fine no one will know
we're doing this it's not like I'm
live-streaming it or anything that's
right I'll change to t-series yeah and
they'll build banty series I don't know
why I said it like it was an obviously
you jump down you mad
I don't have to do anything this is
great all right let's get this bread
let's get the wing there's a tournament
tonight oh that's cool
damn
ah [ __ ] these ones can throw okay well
that's all right yeah I do not condone
this message okay yeah absolutely I got
you man
perfect
we did it we survived the night oh
really
dude I survived it solo all right easy
do I need anything uh yeah I need a
painkiller or something
do you have any oh I see see you don't
want to give it to me Oh fun one do you
want it I don't think I need it I'm
pretty good the game so I don't think I
need like any heels or anything like
that damn it's so bright and nice now
should we stay here then yeah we're
still in it
I'm counter curious to see a boss though
I haven't seen them hell yeah let's go
what he did what he did
cool great god it sounds so bad please
turn it up alright okay alright okay
there we go
is that an Indian in our team hey it is
we have an Indian on our side I don't
even realize tells or thank you for
working undercover Hey
see that's what I'm talking about
alright here's the boss oh okay
I don't see him okay what was that lion
you calling Michael Jackson oh Jesus
Christ
it's Michael Jack's at what is he doing
he throws rocks what the [ __ ]
MJ don't throw rocks Park where do you
get rocks from look at that aim
dude you're tanking that guy Ron keep
raw egg
he's on the down oh nice good job man we
killed MJ we've done something great
here today oh [ __ ] I don't mean to loot
everything
you should take some there was a ghillie
suit oh it looks like I took everything
oops wait I want to wear the ghillie
suit
we got the giveaway see I didn't get it
others do you want the flamethrower
thank you oh hell yeah
and then for what yeah it's getting dark
should we go somewhere you want to fight
him here okay yeah yeah yeah I like this
this is our last thing back to back [ __ ]
who's shooting
now this is great good idea I like this
idea
whoa she says where they come from
oh this [ __ ] guy try to run me over
stream snipers they're worse than
zombies I got to watch out for cars oh
god I got a fat one
cheese ass leave me alone
reload
there's too many dude where are you
where are you where are you Roy I'm
scared dude I'm so dead
oh [ __ ] there is what is he doing I'm
just gonna run for it and then he'll
come on
what kind of bullets do you need hey
what the [ __ ] don't hit me don't hit me
I'm liquors dead there's bullets here
here here in front of me here alright
well if you don't want them there's five
six here yeah you're welcome
so ungrateful whoa whoa there's a guy
with a [ __ ] shield dude
shoot him how good job good job
nice [ __ ] I hate those oh oh I'm out I'm
out I'm going out blasting [ __ ] I'm
gonna run outta my real dude they're so
[ __ ] many what do I do
[Music]
how is it not day yet
okay wait I have bullets I abolished
come here line them up for me I'd say
look at these very epic look
I got 716 a zombie grenade what the [ __ ]
is that oh dude you're gonna God up
through this car here we're saved
I do but have no idea how I drop it but
I only have 80 I don't want to give no
fun you know fine fine I'll drop keep
begging for it the shield guy is still
okay wait wait tank the tank the guy
tank the guy thank the guy thank the guy
I'll run around him shoot him in the ass
you got no bullets okay don't worry
don't worry don't panic don't panic
we're gonna find your bullets and
everything's gonna be all right
everything's gonna be fine just positive
thoughts
PMA oh god the shield guys here the
shield the [ __ ] shield guy I don't
like him okay shield guys are on my tail
I don't like it there you go nice and
yeah yeah keep shielding him nice he
dropped nothing hey that's pretty good
than eight times I don't know if you
need that in this you want 20 but dude
you're so greedy 20 bullets okay fine
I'll drop 20 bullets drop there you go
drop 20 bullets over here and some five
times Jesus it's fine it's fine
all right there's bullets in this
building nice good job wait where are
they where are they [ __ ] other in the
Billy that was amazing
dude we killed Michael Jackson oh Jesus
[ __ ] sorry sighs are they [ __ ] we're not
in the zone not cool all right here we
go jump over okay
well I got a ghillie suit place there's
two bosses around us
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go for this
zone and then it's snake time that's the
plan and if they find me in the grass
then we know their stream sniping so it
doesn't even matter all right I got a
unmute the guy I muted for playing [ __ ]
lasagna I'm sorry sorry man hey you're
still there sorry about the mute man it
was a spur-of-the-moment
oh no I'm I am I am legitimately sorry
but we're back now so it's fine right
okay cool this is eight it all comes
down to this throw away the flamethrower
[ __ ]
you see them cemani damn look at this
dude
nice dude that was [ __ ] nice that
flamethrower is super obvious fine I'll
drop it Jesus I can't drop it now
they're on the other side you got him
there's only one guy left
well we got a circle on no I'm scared
I'm gonna sneak in where oh I see [ __ ]
well I cheese that okay okay okay easy
no I didn't well he has to come here so
I see him by the vehicle yes he's in the
blue now got him once hey chicken dinner
thanks guys good job
very nice happy wheels that's how it's
done
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna join one
more with another party thanks guys
very epic that's how it's done
total gameplay right there and I'm level
11 thanks for all right thanks guys see
you later all right if anyone else wants
to eat my meal
let me check out the chance
[Music]
right yeah I don't know how to invite
them
I can't see it says invited to team and
our who invited
note it was not Tara kills I care like
50 billion times
what are you talking spero kills no it's
zero that's that's what I got all right
some people
oh there I am
what's up guys hey killer made it back
in that we got the Indian spy all right
let's get this another win please boy
who said that oh I probably did I didn't
realize I'm sorry okay yeah I thought
you just weren't speaking okay well well
well I can hear you now goddamn it Jimmy
you lost your spine you messed up Jimmy
all right so how good are you guys at
this from one to ten I don't know why I
don't believe that at all it's the true
but you dye landscape didn't you I don't
know who's talking right now
oh is it garlic I can't see oh it's Lola
okay now you're right I didn't play with
your last game all right well now's your
time to prove your worth even though I'm
the one who's worthless oh because you
were witnessing such amazing gameplay
that you felt like you weren't good
enough yourself yeah I get that
insecurity but that's your own issue
that you need to work out wait so
camping on the door not good then
then how come I won the game uh-huh
excu excuse me zero depth that's what I
got cuz I didn't die a single time
listen I don't need this for my
teammates okay maybe the chat can say
that can't believe this
that's all we need and that's all we're
gonna get if we follow my simple
strategy camping by the door I've been
trying to teach people educate them okay
I still need a helmet I haven't used it
for you okay
very epic so anyone see a helmet let me
know well you don't have a helmet yet
what do you want me to check out this
guy I don't understand you how the gun
the gun the gun oh oh thanks bro
Thanks hey you got ammo for that oh
that's a bro fish
that's definitely brofist worthy yeah
hell yeah
yeah yeah okay thank you
okay well don't we all
okay still have no helmet that's fine
oops
just lucky shots just warming the gun up
a bit
what okay wait saying the middle
building this one don't check the roof
Wow
lie lie much I wait found it never mind
never mind never mind sorry I'm sorry I
didn't see it all right so what's the
strategy here should we just stay here
wait wait I know this I'm kind of pro at
the game so I know like veins and outs
you follow me I know like I know like a
secret thing okay okay I will be okay
that's probably a better idea yeah
where should we stay then let's get the
swinging Hall
the swimming pool like the smaller
building over here oh [ __ ] now where the
campers thank you it's not looting so I
told you I'm Pro [ __ ] pro strats nice oh
there is a little ledge here you can see
it even wow they look so sad goddamn I'm
[ __ ] awful oops
okay I really want to use this gun it's
getting dark I can't aim down the scope
with it what whoa whoa oh yeah hell yeah
yeah all right I should probably save
this one or actually I can't nice
very epic how many kills do you guys
have I see
so weren't you making fun of me for
having 0 kilo slice last time damn they
die fast
bottle ooh damn
this gum [ __ ] owns oh that one you
pissed off the fat one damn [ __ ] I don't
realize it did they why am i punching
nice oh there's more to come
how long is his night oh yeah I saw that
and where I'll punch him there you go
Shirley that's it for the night there
you go
alright are we still in the zone we are
nice god damn I'm good at this game
I should reload we're gonna mute this
guy's one second thank you very much i
witzy shout out to my girl deke Daxi she
beautiful my old channel with 70 K fans
got terminated from nothing last month
ammonia any man it's [ __ ] YouTube
they'll get you I'll get you out of
nowhere
when is he playing minecraft that is a
great question
not right now we're playing pomp g/mol
balance racing it's on the extreme
I'm not going near any bridges Greg why
do you think I'm deliberately dropping
in the middle I know what I'm doing I
need this sort of help don't worry I
appreciate you looking after me but it's
funny so wait is that are they too much
cuz for me they're not allowed at all
man last game that guy seems so upset
that I muted him I completely forgot I'm
sorry oh well let's get back in it
what's up sorry I had to meet you guys
one saying hey eight eight eight I got
some drinks I got some slurps just hit
me up yet the school isn't looted so you
can just look around
should be plenty okay the game RT is not
loud okay good nice aim thank you
I know oh that's probably loud
you might have heard something
oh they're shooting me [ __ ]
why stop
where are they North white oh I see them
now is it zombie nice nice hey now you
gotta kill em good job see real real
pros play without killing people I don't
know if you heard about that you
probably haven't heard of it it is an
achievement hell yeah
well I definitely got it already then
[Laughter]
that's the only achievement I'll ever
get listen I'm getting used to it okay
what do you mean what happened
that's implying I'm not good I'm still
good listen thank you no I really enjoy
it it's a fun game okay yeah I like this
are we missing a guy
now we're all here yeah ooh they're
spitting goddamn that's all I'm trying
really hard here nice where are they
spitting from there Sam
oh [ __ ]
did that on purpose
what happened Oh CPU were good at the oh
[ __ ] I just realized there it is
let's get that liquor Dicker's oh Jesus
[ __ ]
real own cheese sighs my we made it hell
yeah yeah yeah yeah ye and that's how
it's done I see em Sam
ah die zombies these are so [ __ ]
annoying hate them
is it over
ah [ __ ] are you kidding me straight that
must have been a stream sniper we've not
even top ten guys not even top ten
alright well still still GG I will say
still GG
we came we saw and then we came all
right I'm gonna that was my last game
guys thanks for playing
dude leveled up level 12
bye guys bye okay so pop G mobile is
having their one-year-anniversary suit
[Music]
so they're gonna have an exclusive
advance
stop other people's stuff as well
if we get some
very nice
if you guys wanna check out the game
there's a link in the description
download it now add me as a friend I am
pewdiepie forever know it supposed to be
p5 forever number one you can like back
and do your part by eradicating the
teeth I mean the t-virus hashtag the
virus it needs to stop so what you can
do is upload a picture or video using
social media whatever one you want but
hashtag and teats
I mean antivirus and show off your high
as a zombie kill streak and I will check
it out very epic is it loud
what's loud are you guys talking about
happy birthday Jesus Christ the chat is
crazy thank you guys for joining thanks
for everyone for playing it's super fun
and thanks to pop G moment what a lovely
next up next up happy wheels
alright guys that's it for me brofist
since you guys joined it's a brofist
time look at this look at this progress
wait we're out already this door